finances benzaranka who'll talk about
public spending Stuart Adam who will
talk about tax and yahweh's you who will
look at living standards and the welfare
changes
um
any questions that you have please put
into the slido link which everyone uh
has access to and great if you include
your name so we know who you are when
you put your question in all of the
slides and my opening remarks are up um
on the ifs website and hopefully around
about now certainly my opening remarks
will be there
um I'm going to run through those quite
quickly now rather than read them all
out you can you can read the whole lot
if you want
um
I think the key point about yesterday's
event from the Public Finance point of
view is that Jeremy Hunt was actually
well while obviously more fiscally uh
conservative and responsible than his
immediate predecessor quasiquating
actually
um did relatively little to offset some
very big increases in borrowing he set
himself much the loosest set of fiscal
rules that any of his predecessors have
had certainly since 2010
um he decided it's fine to borrow
um to cover current spending and he's
meeting his fiscal rules in five years
Time by a hairs breath
um so this was uh oddly enough and
despite a lot of the coverage not a
particularly uh fiscally
um conservative uh statement Mr Hunt
really did I think the minimum he felt
he could get away with or minimally felt
he needed to do in order to regain some
fiscal credibility and nearly all of the
tightening that he's doing is coming
after the next election there's not very
much at all happening over the next
couple of years indeed spending is
rising
um over the next couple of years now
given the precarious state of the
economy
um uncertainty surrounding the forecast
there is some good reason for that he's
clearly hoping for good news coming
along uh later on so the spending cuts
that he's effectively penciled in post
election aren't needed but remember that
uncertainty runs in both directions
things could turn out worse than
predicted
so he's erring on the side of caution in
terms of protecting spending the economy
in the short run rather than airing on
the side of prioritizing Shoring up the
public finances it's worth saying
um uh that the obr while not cheerful uh
is a lot more cheerful than the bank of
England the bank of England's forecasts
are much gloomier than the obr forecast
so the the chancellor must at least be
grateful that he's responding to the obr
and not to the bank if the bank is right
then even more pain is going to be uh
required it's a strange Quirk of the
current system but monetary policy and
fiscal policy are made off the back of
two quite different but official
um forecasts
now there's a curiosity here borrowing
is going to be high into the foreseeable
future
tax is going to be very high indeed
indeed our tax burden is going to settle
at its highest level in history relative
to uh national income so
um lots and lots of borrowing and lots
and lots of tax revenues you might think
well lots and lots of spending
um that kind of makes sense doesn't it
but actually those post-election
spending plans are really pretty or
steer that's a pretty nasty place to be
hi boring high debt High tax and public
spending on the strain now how how are
all of those things consistent with one
another well part of the answer lies in
the fact that we just got a whole lot
poorer that's the central fact that
underlies most of what we heard uh
yesterday
part of the answer lies in the
extraordinary scale of expected spending
on debt interest that looks like
doubling relative to forecast hitting a
hundred billion of pounds a year by the
end of the forecast period so we're
going to be spending more on debt
interest uh than on any individual
Public Service bar the NHS so interest
rates are up we've been borrowing an
awful lot uh a lot of that's held by the
bank of England where we have to pay the
base rate on that on that debt uh borrow
more over the next few years all of that
is coming very much home to roost we are
discovering rather painfully that
borrowing really is not a free lunch
um that increase in the interest higher
spending on health and on benefits
particular pensioner benefits entirely
explains the growth and the size of the
state and the period uh from 2019 into
the later years of this decade with
defense spending cuts off the table an
aging population and apparently
pressures everywhere else you look
I have to say my guess is we have
started a new era in this case a new era
of higher Taxation and higher spending
is a fraction of national income and
hence a bigger State it's quite
remarkable as you'll see in some of the
charts later on it is a sharp change
one hesitates to make forecasts about
sharp changes being persistent but I
would be most surprised if the tax
burden gets back down to its long-term
pre-covert average at any time
in the next several decades quite
honestly higher taxes a bigger State
look to me to be here to stay unless
something quite radical changes
so on public spending
um uh over the next couple of years the
numbers don't look too bad despite
higher inflation real Public Service
spending looks like it's due to grow
only really marginally less quickly than
was planned last September and remember
last September's spending review looked
pretty generous relative to where we've
been over the last
decade now in part that's because the
chancellor has found more money for
health and remember there was quite a
lot more money
um announced last year for health more
money for schools more money for local
government to particularly pay for
social care
um so there's more money there for those
bits of Public Services no more for the
rest
it's also worth saying the figures in
terms of growth are flattered by
underspends in the base year which makes
the increases look bigger and also so
some I don't know if quirks is quite the
right word but the way the GDP deflator
is defined and that is how we Define
what is a real increase in spending
makes a big difference here the GDP
deflator the measure of economy-wide
inflation is much lower than CPI
inflation all of that does mean that the
government despite those numbers not
looking too bad in those kinds of terms
government's still not going to be able
to fund pay rise is that anywhere near
match inflation in the public sector
from within the planned spending totals
unless there's a big loss of jobs public
pay setting in my view will remain one
of the biggest challenges facing this
government over the rest of this year
and into the rest of the period up to
the next election public pay don't
forget has done even worse than private
sector pay over the last decade and is
doing even worse than private sector pay
at the moment the fact that nurses
teachers and so on are balloting the
strike action is an indication of the
scale of that problem
beyond the next two years
um all the spending numbers it's worth
saying should be taken with a very large
pinch of salt uh after all they are
spending penciled in for after the next
election if they are kept to they'll
mean Cuts relatively modest ones but
Cuts nonetheless to most public services
I have to say it's unlikely that they
will actually be kept to I'd be willing
to wager quite a considerable sum that
spending will turn out higher than
planned it literally always does
um of course if it does and the uh
forecasts are right that will imply
either more taxes or more borrowing
alongside I in my opening remarks I want
to make two specific points about
funding about spending the first is it's
awful Isn't it that the social care
reforms will not now be implemented next
year as planned there's another two-year
delay I really do fear that yet another
delay where are we a decade after the
dill not uh report another two-year
delay May well amount to a death now to
these vital changes government really
should not be making and then reneging
on promises like this which matters so
much to vulnerable people second there's
a question what on Earth is happening to
incapacity and disability benefits since
March the obr has eyes upwards its
estimates are spending on these benefits
by a staggering seven and a half billion
pounds a year and estimates the number
of recipients Will Rise by more than a
million over the next couple of years
and that is that is an astonishing and
really quite worrying Trend if true uh
relates to this big issue of course of
people dropping out of the labor market
at the same time we have a delay until
2028 in moving existing claimants of out
of work health related benefits onto
Universal Credit with no explanation
given
um Universal Credit is supposed to be
fully rolled out well before then I have
to say this looks horribly like an
effort to push a relatively small
increase in spending to beyond the
forecast Horizon and ensue doing so
delaying the full rollout of the new
system all of this very odd very
concerning more for us to do to dig into
what's going on on there but an issue to
worry about
on living standards
um of course the most striking figures
in the obr report are those pertaining
uh to the seven percent uh fall that
they're forecasting in real household
disposable income per person over the
next couple of years the biggest fall in
living memory possibly ever uh in uh in
income growth over a two-year period
this is going to hit everyone of course
it's a manifestation of the fact that we
are just poorer uh a significantly
poorer as a result uh not least of
what's been happening to Energy prices
broadly speaking I think it's those on
middling sorts of incomes who will feel
the biggest hit they're not going to
benefit from the targeted support to
those on mean sensitive benefits their
wages are falling in real terms their
taxes are rising their housing costs are
probably Rising middle England I think
is set for quite a shock
and of course all of this follows a
painful decade median real wages Etc are
made at much the same level as they were
at the start of the 2010s earnings and
incomes have barely risen on some
measures it looks like will be an
astonishing 30 percent worse off than we
might have expected to have been had
pre-financial crisis Trends continued
um
it's worth saying significant support to
benefit recipients on top of capping
average energy bills at three thousand
pound will provide a better and more
targeted approach to high energy prices
than proposed by Liz truss and put all
of the tax and Welfare changes together
this was a progressive fiscal statement
tax Rises for the rich increased
targeting on the poor it's just that
virtually all of us can expect to end up
poorer
um finally on tax
um it Remains the case that the big tax
changes coming in over the next few
years are those that had already been
announced corporation tax revenues will
hit record levels
um as the as the rate Rises to 25 now I
never expected I'd be saying that in the
early
2020s freezes to income tax allowances
and thresholds constitute a very very
big tax increase indeed the measures
announced yesterday were modest by
comparison in the longer term the
biggest is the freezing of the point at
which employers start to pay National
Insurance contributions though more
immediately the energy profits Levy is
due to raise more reducing the point at
which the additional 45 rate of income
tax kicks in uh a big a big statement
from the point of view of um a baton
actually raises less than a billion
pounds a year as as does the reduction
in dividend allowance the cut to the
capital gains tax allowances raises less
than half a billion all of those changes
will largely hit the better off that
they are hardly game changers what is a
game changer is that there is a huge
structure structural change to income
tax when the additional rate was
introduced in 2010 only around 200 000
people paid it now anyone earning over a
hundred thousand pounds pays 60 tax
anyone earning over 125 140 pays 45 tax
that's four percent of adults about 2
million people by the middle of this
decade paying at 60 or 45 that's more
than we're paying the higher 40 rate
back in 1990. meanwhile there'll
probably be eight million people paying
at that 40 rate this is a big it's a
fundamental it's a complete change to
our income tax system and a big increase
in the marginal rate of tax faced by
millions beyond that of course there
were lots of tax changes there were tax
changes the Capitals capital gains taxes
dividends taxes business rates
um there was a vehicle excise duty
um there was stamp Duty
what what uh what what what what what is
what all of those changes have in common
is I saw no sense of direction no sense
of strategy no sense of how any of these
fit into a long-term view of where the
tax system is going to go we've had a
huge extensive review of business rates
they're being cut supposedly extension
to a temporary cut retail and
Hospitality that's going to be really
hard to undo where are we going with
business rates how are we going to tax
electric vehicles in the long run
increasing vehicle access Duty on them
is a it is is is a tiny change doesn't
tell us anything about how we're going
to replace uh fuel Duty are we actually
going to properly reform capital gains
tax rather than fiddling around with the
allowance and so on this really matters
as taxes rise in general
so to conclude
Chancellor is hemmed in by Rising
interest rates and Dreadful growth
prospects
um in being hemmed in he's decided
largely to allow borrowing to rise and
to put off the tough decisions for
another couple of years he may well hope
that things will look better by then or
perhaps that it will be somebody else's
problem
um what we're really doing of course is
reaping the costs of long-term failure
to grow the economy the effects of an
aging population and high levels of past
borrowing after years of stagnation
household incomes are set to fall and
then recover only gradually our taxes
rise and public services continue to
struggle what a combination the truth is
of course we just got a lot poorer we're
in for a long hard unpleasant Journey a
journey that's been made more arduous
than it might have been by a series of
economic owned goals Mr punt Mr Hunt
appears to have recognized this after
years of cachism his colleagues and the
opposition and we the voters are going
to need to take that board that fact on
on board too I will now hand over to
Carl
thank you very much Paul
I will share my screen and I'm afraid I
can't turn my video on at the moment but
hopefully people can see the slides
so I'm going to talk about how the
outlook for the Public Finance Finance
has changed and what Jeremy Hunt decided
to do about it and I'm going to
highlight some of the key risks around
the forecast going forwards
enough
as Paul said the starting point and as I
guess was widely expected is that the
bank the obr revised down its forecast
for economic growth over the next few
years so these are the forecasts that
were produced in March for steady if not
unspectacular growth and these are the
forecasts that presented yesterday for a
recession and then stronger growth
resuming but still the economy running
well below what was expected in March a
downgrade of about four percent in the
middle of 2025.
things could be worse than that there's
clearly uncertainty about the path of
the economy and if you take the bank of
England's forecast produced just a
couple of weeks ago and you take their
forecast produced on the idea that
interest rates will follow Market
expectations well they that if that was
the case the downgrades of the obr
forecast would be more than twice what
we saw yesterday
and even if we take the bank of
England's forecast that's predicated on
the idea that interest rates remain
constant rather than Rising you'd still
see a bigger downgrade
so uncertainty around the obr's forecast
and certainly we and Jeremy Hunt must
hope that they are right and not the
bank of England or even better that
things turn out better than what the obr
expects
is it the case that the obr is
particularly optimistic well actually if
you compare them to a wider set of
forecasters it's not clear it is the
case this shows the obr's forecast
alongside the bank of England's the imfs
and the other independent forecasts that
are surveyed by the treasury and it
looks like the obr at least at the
moment is around the middle of the pack
so there's uncertainty on both sides
so what did this do to the outlook for
government borrowing over the next few
years
well these are the forecasts for
borrowing that were produced in March a
deficit of over 120 billion pounds in
the last Financial year but falling down
to kind of just over 30 billion pounds
by 26 27.
but there's been lots of changes since
there's been changes to the economy like
I just showed you the outlook for the
economy is weaker that adds to borrowing
going forwards
so this tells how big those underlying
changes since March have been and
actually a Big Driver of that has been
an increase in the outlook for debt
interest spending that more than
explains the increase in underlying
change coming from underlying changes
this year and explains a very big chunk
in future years so let's look at the
outlook for debt interest spending in a
bit more detail
this chart is showing you how much the
government's been spending on debt
interest as a share of national income
in each year going back and if we take
the March forecast at the time it looked
like there'd be a big spike in spending
this year caused by higher inflation but
then if we look through that Spike
spending would return back down to the
low levels that we've been enjoying
since 2000 so no no evidence of a
long-run problems and debt interest
there
unfortunately that situation seems to
have changed the blue line here shows
the obr's forecast from yesterday that
spike in debt interest spending is now
expected to be much bigger a record
level debt interest spending at the
level we've not seen for over 70 years
although I should add it wasn't uncommon
before that
but more importantly when you look
through that Peak you see that debt
interest spending Falls but it
stabilizes at a level that's still
pretty high by recent years it's High by
the standards that we've seen since
2000. so essentially a combination of
all of that debt we've accumulated since
2008 and the fact that the outlook for
interest rates is now higher than we've
been used to over the last decade leaves
debt interest spending higher
now here's an area where I think there's
actually some cause for optimism in the
OBS forecast
while they're advised up their outlook
for debt interest spending I think it's
possible that debt interest spending
won't rise as sharply as they expect
so these are the forecasts that were
produced by the obr in March for debt
interest spending and these are the
forecasts that they presented us with
yesterday so you can see in 2627 they
were projecting that debt interest
spending will now be 95 billion pounds
double the 47 they were predicting back
in March
now these forecasts were debt interest
spending the obr produce take Market
expectations of what interest rates will
be that's one approach an alternative
might be to say what are independent
forecasters saying about where they
think interest rates are going and let's
use that when we're trying to project
debt interest spending
so if we take the average of independent
forecasters expectations it is the case
they think that that interest rates will
be a lot higher than what was expected
by the obr back in March but it's
actually lower than current market
expectations so while there'd still be a
big increase in debt interest spending
relative to March it wouldn't be as big
as the obr expects so in the coming
Financial year debt interest spending
would end up about 9 billion pounds
lower than the obr expectation still 50
billion pounds more than they thought
back in March but in 2627 the increase
would be reduced by 17 billion pounds
this is an area of the forecast where we
must very much hope that things could
turn out better than the OVR expects
as Paul said there was also another
change in the forecast that looked quite
puzzling and concerning and that relates
to one part of the working age benefits
bill
the obr revised up by seven and a half
billion pounds how much it expects to
spend on disability and other health
related benefits in 2627 and that's over
and above the upwards revision it made
because of higher inflation
so this is coming from a huge increase
in the numbers that the obr expects to
be receiving these benefits previously
expected 8.2 million people to be
receiving these benefits in 2627 that
was just in March it now expects 9.3
million so 1.1 million increase in its
forecast over just a not eight month
period
now there's relatively limited
information provided by the obr about
this we're going to follow up and try
and find out if there's more on what's
going on but our reading of the evidence
suggests that it's driven mostly by the
benefits which are available to those
who are out of work because of having a
work limiting health issue so it's not
the benefits we think that are there for
people who are in or out of work who are
getting support to help them with the
extra costs of that disability we think
it's the out of work benefits building
capacity benefits that is driving it
I think it's also worth noting that the
Autumn statement also said that for
people who are on these out of working
capacity benefits who haven't yet moved
across to Universal Credit they're going
to delay moving them across until 2028.
that's despite the fact just last April
the government committed to have them
having them all moved over by the end of
2024.
now we won no we don't know but we
wonder if there's some connection with
the increase in caseloads
but there could be another explanation
it could be that by pushing it to 2028
what the government's trying to do is
just push the costs of it having to do
this change until after the end of the
forecast Horizon and we note that the
government is also trying to merge
pension credit with pension a housing
benefit and the ultimate statement
yesterday also announced that that is
also going to be delayed until 2028
which will also have the impact of
reducing public spending throughout the
forecast Horizon
let's go back to the outlook for
borrowing the other thing that happened
between March and before yesterday's
Autumn statement is we've had a whole
load of policy changes so we had the
energy price guarantee announced by Liz
truss we also had things like the
abolition of the Health and Social care
level so these also acted to increase
the outlook for borrowing
so what that line shows you on this
chart now is what the outlook for
borrowing would have been had Jeremy
Hunt stood up yesterday and said
actually I'm not going to implement any
new measures I'm just going to let
borrowing go along this path I'm going
to allow the underlying changes and the
policy measures announced since March to
push borrowing up
and you can see that would be quite a
substantial increase in borrowing the
difference between the March forecast
and that free Autumn statement forecast
in The Current financial year is about
80 billion pounds and in the last year
and 2627 it's running at about 90
billion pounds so let's look at that
increase in borrowing that's shown by
these dots on this chart this is the
increase that would have happened had
Jeremy Hunt not done anything yesterday
and we can answer the question how much
has each decided to try and offset that
increase in borrowing with new spending
cuts or new tax prizes
and that's shown by these bars and the
answer for the current Parliament is
just really not trying to do very much
to offset that increase in borrowing it
could be good economic reasons for that
but it does mean we'll be borrowing a
lot more in the next couple of financial
years
beyond that there is a fiscal
consolidation plan that starts to get
into action but even in 2627 you can see
that the new tax Rises and spending cuts
are offsetting less than half of the
increase in borrowing that we've seen
since March
we can also break those measures down
into whether they are permanent spending
cuts whether they're temporary tax Rises
the energy and the windfall tax on
energy companies or whether they are
permanent tax Rises
and on our calculations the new tax
Rises we heard about yesterday are
explaining about 40 percent of the
planned fiscal tightening in 2728 so 40
from tax Rises 60 from spending cuts and
we can compare that to previous
consolidations George Osborne when he
was Chancellor uh set out to try and
achieve a physical consolidation that
was 80 spending cuts and 20 tax Rises so
Jeremy Hunt's plan is more tax heavy
less spending heavy than that but when
Ken Clark in 1993 was trying to fix the
public finances our calculations suggest
that he went for an approach that was
roughly 50 50 tax Rises and spending
cuts so one that was more tax heavy than
what Jeremy Hunt is now trying to do
so where does this leave uh taxes as a
share of national income in the United
Kingdom well if we go back to March
these were the forecasts for taxes a
share of GDP over time you can see that
they were set to rise and reach levels
that we hadn't actually sustained since
the 1950s
after the mini budget Chancellor quasi
quatang was still seeing uh tax as a
share of national income at pretty high
levels by UK standards but you had them
on a downward path because of that big
package of tax cuts that he announced in
his mini budget
Jeremy Hunt is much more than reversed
to that the new tax Rises means that the
taxes as a share of national income are
set to grow well above what was expected
even in March and be well above anything
that the UK's economy the UK economy has
sustained in its history so taxes as a
share of mission and national income
High by UK historical standards it's
worth saying that the other successful
economies in Western Europe and
Scandinavia that sustain higher tax
burdens than this
so government borrowing up in the near
term where does this leave the path for
government debt or back in March when
Rishi sunak was Chancellor he wanted to
have debt falling as a share of GDP
three years out and he set out some
forecasts that showed that this was
going to be achieved but only just he
didn't really have debt on a decisively
falling path it was gradually falling
there was a margin of error some
Headroom he had of about 28 billion
pounds that sounds like a huge sum of
money but in the context of trying to
forecast the change in debt three years
out it's really not a big margin
where are we now well the extra
borrowing over the next couple of years
pushes debt up and at the end of the
forecast Horizon when Jeremy Hunt is now
trying to make sure debtors for winning
is trying to get it falling in five
years time not in three years time he's
just about got it falling believe me
that line is coming down even though you
can barely see it he has a Headroom of
nine billion pounds that's absolutely
tiny it suggests that on current policy
settings there's roughly a 50 50 chance
on whether debt will actually be falling
in 27 28.
and there are some big risks around this
forecast
one set of risks relate to the revenue
side the current Baseline for forecasts
assume that each April the rate of fuel
duties will go up in line with the RPI
then that hasn't happened since 2011
moreover they assumed that the 5p cut to
field Duty that's currently in place
will be allowed to expire in April so
that'll if that all goes ahead that
implies that fuel duties would go up by
a whopping 23 percent in April I predict
that's not going to happen if we freeze
rates again it will cost about 6 billion
pounds in 23 24.
as Stuart we'll talk about we've also
decided to freeze many allowances in the
tax system and in particular the
personal allowance and income tax is set
to be frozen for six years in the last
year of the forecast Horizon that rate
is about 1.3 billion pounds and I think
there's a genuine question about whether
that's credible in my lifetime the
maximum freeze that we have managed is
two years so it'll be interesting to see
whether a six year freeze really does
happen
so to conclude there's been a big
deterioration in the outlook for the
public finances since March due to a
much weaker economic Outlook and much of
that deterioration is actually explained
by higher interest rates pushing up debt
interest spending and actually that
increase in debt interest spending could
be smaller than what the obr expects
there is some room for optimism there I
think
the mesh is outlined by Jeremy Hunt and
your Autumn statement only counteracts a
small share of those that deterioration
in the public finances and of the
measures he set out we reckon that tax
risers are explaining about 40 of the
tightening spending cuts about 60
percent
the risks to this some of the policy
risks are will the tax will taxes as a
share of national income really be
sustained at 37 of national income
there's also risks on the spending side
yesterday Jeremy Hunt trimmed his
planned level of spending in 27 28 by 30
billion pounds that raises the question
of whether the spending plans can really
be kept to and that's something that Ben
zaranco will now address in his
presentation thank you
thanks Carl good morning everybody
I'll now run quickly through the impact
of yesterday's announcements on public
services
uh I want to focus first on the short
term I'll turn to the medium term
picture after that
um there was really two budgets
yesterday one for the next few years and
one for the after the next election
so the starting point for the short-term
Outlook is that last year's spending
review held last October the government
set out three years of detailed
department by Department funding
settlements those run for the three
years up until
2024-25 now they're fixed in cash terms
that means they don't automatically
adjust if inflation or pay Awards differ
from what was initially assumed uh the
cash budget has to take that into it
into account
now despite what we might have expected
and give what's happening to headline
consumer inflation
the overall generosity of those plans
hasn't actually shifted much on paper
so just to illustrate that if we look on
the left hand side here I'm going to
show you average real terms growth over
the five-year Parliament the green bar
is what was planned for
last year's spending review the blue bar
is what is now implied based on
yesterday's plans overall day-to-day
departmental spending so stripping out
investment this is for spending on
things like staff and day-to-day running
costs you can see very similar and if we
just look at the three years covered by
the spending
you period again very very similar if
anything a slightly faster growth rate
now that's puzzling given what we keep
hearing about including our own
Publications talking about inflation
eating away at the generosity of
departmental budgets so what's going on
well there's a few things first of all
um the measure of inflation that we
typically use
for such calculations is called the GDP
deflator to measure of economy-wide
domestic inflation
um that's going to be higher in the
short term but not that much higher and
actually is focused by the obr to be
lower in the medium term so let me show
you that green bars here show you the
annual forecast inflation as per this
measure last October yellow bars show
you march and the blue bars show you as
of yesterday so you can see the blue
bars there GDP deflator inflation
spiking up to almost five percent this
year now that's well below CPI which is
running up more like double that rate
and about three percent next year then
you can see on the right hand side it
falling back and actually being lower
than what was previously forecast and
lower inflation means a given level of
cash increases equates to a faster real
terms growth rate so in the short term
why is it so perhaps unexpectedly low
well it's being held down by the fact
that import prices are growing much
faster than export prices much of the
inflation we're facing in the UK is
driven by Rising costs of imported food
and imported energy and imported fuel
um because the GDP deflated measures
domestic inflation those don't feature
and there's also some it impacts from
unwinding lockdown effects on public
services then in the medium term weak
Consumer Price inflation and consumer
demand combined with slower growth in
the government part of of consumption
holds that down and that's why you've
got this this very low below one percent
rate of inflation in the later years
so those lower rates of inflation
flatter the real terms growth in the
government's spending plans there are
very good reasons to think that that
measure of inflation well perhaps the
best one we have isn't going to
perfectly capture cost pressures on
public services there are particular
challenges around hey Awards so the GDP
deflector next year is expected to be
about three percent CPI about five and a
half percent so if government
departments offer inflation matching pay
award to their to their workers that's
clearly going to exceed the cost
pressures that would be suggested if you
just look at the GDP deflector and pay
is going to be a very difficult policy
area it's extremely hard to see how you
could have uh pay Awards matching
inflation or indeed real terms pay Rises
the public sector workers over the next
few years without either cutting back on
head counts or cutting back severely on
some other area that will determine
service quality
there was also some extra money
yesterday there was extra money for the
NHS and for schools a couple of billion
each and there was quite a bit of extra
money for local government and it's not
very often we get to say this at these
post budget events but local government
was actually a particular winner with
more money from Grants uh being allowed
to raise more and council tax some
compensation for
um business rates indexation change and
also reallocating some funding that was
previously earmarked to implement the
social care funding reforms which as
Paul said been delayed and might
eventually get canned entirely but that
frees up money that can be spent on
other things so councils particularly
those with social care responsibilities
did fairly well out of yesterday's
announcements other less fortunate
budgets will instead be left facing a
squeeze from inflation it will be our
estimate that squeeze might be between 5
and 15 billion of the spending group
period depending on how you measure it
that's clearly going to be very
difficult for other other budgets to
absor all
there's also a final thing which is that
big under spends last year by
departments lower the starting point
they lower the Baseline so increases
relative to a lower Baseline those
percentages look larger
so all together
um the overall generation paper hasn't
changed much pay decisions look very
difficult
there might be good reasons to think
that the actual cost pressures are a bit
greater than it's suggested by the
official figures and if you are not
schools local government or the NHS
you're being asked to squeeze your
budget and that's going to be painful
then after 2025
um there were some cuts for the
government's plans
for spending so that you can see that
here you can see in the left hand side
the extra money there for the NHS and
social care and schools but you can see
on the right hand side
reductions in planned spending
um now you can see the yellow bar there
is the cut in what was pencil did for
Aid spending the government originally
was
applying for Aid to return to 0.7 of GDP
it will now be held at 0.5 percent of
GDP one Quirk yesterday was that was
while the chancellor dropped and changed
his headline fiscal rules he left his
original fiscal rules as the um thing
that will determine when Aid goes back
to 0.
seven percent of national income we
still have to be running a current
budget surplus for that to happen which
is not expected to happen over the
entire forecast period
so how did they manage that would they
actually just basically tweaked the
spending assumption that is applied
Beyond 2025 so previously average
day-to-day departmental funding was set
to grow by more than three percent per
year above inflation that's now one
percent
um but a one percent increase on average
when combined with increases for some
areas it's probably going to mean cuts
for other less fortunate what we might
call unprotected budgets so the obr
provided some new useful analysis of
this yesterday they showed that if the
overall day-to-day budget Rises by one
percent per year you give the NHS 3.1
percent which is what it was intended to
get over the um this five-year
Parliament
you keep per pupil funding in schools
flat but because pupil numbers are set
to fall it means you could
reduce overall schools spending by a bit
your whole debt uh defense and age
spending constant as a fraction of
national income
you're left look at that red bar cutting
everything else by about 0.7 per year if
you want to stay within those plans so
that's one reasonable uh guess or
estimate of what those plans might imply
of Public Services
now that's not the only one we can
consider alternative scenarios in
particular scenarios where the
government provides extra funding so
let's consider a different set of
assumptions maybe the NHS grows more
like its long run average rate somewhat
like 3.8 percent rather
than 3.1 perhaps that would better allow
the NHS to deal with the substantial
pandemic pressures post-pandemic
pressures it's facing number of code
patients it has the scale of waiting
lists for example and to put in place a
long-term Workforce plan and maybe offer
some slightly more generous pay Awards
let's assume that overall schools
funding remains flat so rather than
falling in line with pupil numbers
you've still got to have the same number
of classrooms and schools in the short
term so it might be difficult to cut
spending
uh defense let's instead assume that it
rises towards two and a half percent of
GDP that's more in line with what Boris
Johnson and his trust had committed to
and actually more in line with what
Jeremy Hunt promised when he was willing
to be prime minister a few short years
ago
and if we hold age constant as a
fraction national income and freeze
everything else avoid making Cuts well
you'd have to find about 17 billion
pounds extra by the end of the period if
you didn't find 17 billion extra and you
wanted to do all those things you'd have
to cut those in protected budgets by
about three percent per year
now 17 billion pounds in the scale of
some of the huge numbers Carl was
talking about isn't enormous uh it's
well within the Realms of possibility
it's also roughly what recent experience
might suggest is likely so if we look at
the last four spending reviews
and we look at these provisional
spending totals that were penciled in by
various chancellors and then we look at
what actually happened when they came to
holding a spending review allocating it
between departments making those actual
tough decisions about where the cuts are
going to fall
well they always ended up getting topped
up so you can see Top-Up varies in scale
but on average the final year of these
provisional plans
um gets tugged up by about 3.7 percent
if history repeats itself that will be
about 18 billion pounds extra by the end
of the period very similar to the 17
billion I showed you on the previous
slide so you might think of that as a
sort of reasonable estimate of what
might get added to spending plans and
that combined with for example
um freezing fuel Duty would take the
chance the further away from delivering
on these fiscal objectives
now turning to Capital or investment
spending again it was a story a sort of
a game of two halves in the shorts and
the chancellor stuck to his existing
plans but then after 2025 he penciled in
a cash terms freeze now our cash terms
freeze when inflation is positive and
Rising
um and when the economy is growing means
that investment will fall in real terms
and Falls a fraction of national income
so showing here
um how public sector investment has
evolved over time and what it looks like
over the forecast period you can see
that it's set to be still above where
it's been for most of the past 40 years
still above two percent of GDP but you
can see lower than it would have been
under pre-autumn statement plans about
15 billion law in the final year the
challenge is that the chancellor has
said his three priorities will be energy
Innovation and infrastructure but if you
protect those budgets if you protect for
example investments in energy
infrastructure and research fund funding
and transport and digital because those
things are all important well if overall
all spending is falling does that mean a
squeeze on other things does that mean
for example a squeeze on a capital
budget for the NHS or the prison system
or the further education system there
might still be difficult choices to be
made here even though overall investment
spending will remain at what is a fairly
high level at least by UK standards
so to sum up there's some extra money in
the short term for schools NHS and local
governments that's undoubtedly will be
welcome other less fortunate public
services will have to absorb cost
pressures from higher inflation there
will still be some very difficult
choices about public sector pay sticking
to those cash spending plans for the
next few few years is very difficult to
see how that's consistent with inflation
matching pay Awards there could be
another round of potential real terms
pay cuts of public sector workers and
potentially around the strikes and
response it's also worth saying that
there might be more money available for
things like the NHS but there's still a
potential disconnect between the funding
available and what they're being asked
to deliver the extra cash for the NHS
for example came with a list of
additional asks in terms of what it's
going to do about ambulance waiting
times and Urgent Care and things like
that and so there's also there's a
danger here particularly with the
substantial cost presses cost precious
departments are facing is that the
funding available isn't enough still to
deliver on the government's Public
Service objectives
and after 2025 the plans look in our
judgment implausibly tight the hope is
clearly that they'll never have to be
implemented or at least someone else
will have to implement them and that has
to cast some doubt and The credibility
of the overall Public Finance
forecasts that's all from me thanks very
much
thanks man good morning everyone
um just let me share my screen hopefully
you can all see that
um so I'm going to talk through
um the biggest changes to personal and
business taxation that the chancellor
announced yesterday
um starting with changes to income tax
and National Insurance thresholds
um now the thresholds for
um income tax and employee National
Insurance are already being frozen for
uh four years yesterday that was
extended for a further
um two years along with extensions to
various other freezes and the thresholds
until now the threshold for employers
National Insurance that hadn't been
frozen that's now being frozen until the
same point as well
um and the chance to reduce the point at
which you start paying about the 45
additional rate of income tax from 150
000 pounds to 125
140 pounds the reason for that specific
number and it's because once your income
exceeds a hundred thousand pounds your
personal allowance gets withdrawn
creating an effective sixty percent
income tax and above a hundred thousand
pounds
125 140 pounds is where that stand ends
so your mail goes straight from that
into the forty five percent ban
um and that final change
um will increase the number of
additional rate taxpayer pays by about
350 000 pounds so just the increase from
yesterday's announcements is more than
the total number of additional rate
taxpayers
um that there were when the additional
rate was first introduced and this just
is upcoming on top of
um a long line of uh freezes now it's
now the case that essentially every
significant threshold in the income tax
National Insurance
um system is being frozen over a long
time Horizon now that's just not a
sensible way to make policy
um it means that the size of the tax
rise depends hugely on what inflation
turns out to be it's an accidental and
arbitrary outcome of that rather than
being the result of a deliberate policy
choice so just to take an example the
original four-year freeze to income
touch thresholds have been due to raise
eight billion pounds when it was first
announced by the summer we thought that
would on course a raise more like 30
billion pounds almost four times as much
inflation expectations are now a bit
lower so that's now down to 24 billion
pounds although there are now additional
freezers on top you can see it just goes
up and down according to what inflation
turns out to be and clearly we can have
no idea what that'll be
um three or four years down the line
so what what do these changes mean for
people's uh incomes so this shows
um
how uh people's net take-home pay after
tax
um will change
um according to their level of earnings
and this um first yellow line shows what
it looked like before the Autumn
statement the changes that we already
knew about if we add in the changes that
were announced yesterday
um you see the tax Rises for pretty much
um all income levels
um have got bigger
um again depends a lot on what inflation
turns out to be but maybe 180 200 pounds
more in tax per year for most taxpayers
something more like 1500 pounds more tax
per year
um for those above 150 000 pounds
um a year but bear in mind that's not
necessarily
um a bigger percentage of their income
um
so
this long period of freezing thresholds
particularly when inflation is so high
will obviously increase the number of
taxpayers and the number of people in
higher tax funds now this shows how the
number of higher and additional rate
taxpayers has changed over by the end of
these freezes we reckon almost 15
percent of the adult population will be
paying high rate tax that's up from
eight percent just a couple of years ago
and under four percent
1990 when um individual taxation was
first introduced
um and there'll actually be two million
people just
above the hundred thousand pound
threshold and therefore facing
um 45 or 60 marginal rates of income tax
and more people above the hundred
thousand pound threshold than there were
higher rate taxpayers in total uh in
1990.
earnings and council tax are the
transfer amounts that councils would be
um allowed to increase their council tax
by up to five percent a year for the
next five years as up from a limit of
three percent
um this year the obr reckons that over
the uh by the end of the five years that
will be raising almost five billion
pounds a year uh more for councils
um now that's assuming that councils um
essentially take up uh
freedom to increase council tax rates in
full
um this chart shows that if they do that
um
rather than say increasing it by three
percent a year that would increase
council tax bills by about 160 pounds uh
a year on average and would leave us on
calls to have the highest ever real
terms council tax bills
um now actually that might not be that
surprising we might expect Council taxi
rise in real terms we might expect it to
keep Pace with income sale keep paid at
house prices not not that incomes are
rising that much at the moment
but the underlying Point yeah the bigger
point is that this is essentially an
increase in an unreformed tax it cancel
that remains regressive distortionary
and above all still based on hopelessly
out of date property values
in contrast business rates is being
brought up to date up from next April
and it'll be based on 2021
um property values rather than 20 25th
2015 values
um that's a very good thing
um the government is
all right
be voting 1.7 billion pounds to ensure
that those whose uh tax bills go up as a
result of having that property revalued
we'll see the bills rise only gradually
whereas those who've built with four get
um Can can see it fall immediately
the chancellor also announced two other
cuts to business rates it wasn't just a
tax raising Autumn statement yesterday
first was a six percent real term cut to
business rates uh across the board
so if I show you now
um the tax payable as a percentage of
property value
um it reduces it from this light green
line to the darker line
um so for a typical business with a
rateable value of say 20 or 30
000 pounds that'll be worth a few
hundred pounds a year off their business
rates bill
the other cut to business rates was more
specific it was a 75 reduction for
retail hospitality and Leisure
businesses
um for one year only so that will be
worth more like thousands of thousands
off and hundreds of pounds for a typical
qualifying business
now that's supposed to be for one year
only is coming on the back of a history
of a series of other reliefs like this
but actually is even more generous than
the 50 relief
um that this sector is getting at the
moment which was supposed to be a
temporary thing
um to help um with the the tail end and
the aftermath of the pandemic it's quite
hard to see what the right
so another huge even bigger relief for
retail for one year only and but given
the history of History it must be
doubtful whether it really will be for
one year only and the more people
believe that this is going to be
permanent or keep being repeated the
less effective it'll be at supporting
the sector because the more we'll tend
to see rents on these properties uh
increase so that it benefits landlords
rather than the retailers themselves
again the broader point with business
rights here is that it looks like the
government doesn't look like business
rates and the effects that it has but it
doesn't quite know what to do about it
it had a fundamental review of business
rates but it didn't lead to fundamental
reform yesterday they confirmed they
wouldn't be going ahead with a move to
an online sales tax which I think is
very good that they're not doing that
but they just seem to be responding by
saying well we'll have ad hoc reductions
and adjustments to business rates here
and there
um
whenever we think is needed or suitable
that's not really an adequate solution
we need a better vision for what
business rates should be doing
the other big announcement on business
taxation was of course um extensions to
the windfall tax
um on the energy sector
so this shows um first of all the
standard rate of corporation tax in the
UK and how it's changed over time
profits from North Sea oil and gas have
always been subject to higher tax rates
than this and the energy process Lobby
that was announced in May said that
rather than the uh tax rate for profits
on oil and gas continuing at that level
um it would go up to an effective rate
of 65 for up to three and a half years
yesterday the chancellor announced that
the rate would be higher and that it
would last for longer and this almost
doubled
um the revenue that um he expects to get
from it of course again very uncertain
depends on what happens to oil and gas
prices and therefore the um profits from
uh these companies this is a pretty
substantial
um
if what if temporary tax increase
they're really just taking
um tax rate on oil and gas profits to
around the levels that they've been
um for well much of the previous uh 40
or 50 years
the rental types is also extended in
another way as well as
increasing it for nausea oil and gas
producers
um there was a new windfall tax on a low
carbon electricity generators
um which again the the uh Chancellor
expense to raise a fairly substantial 14
billion pounds over the five years or so
but um it's uh in place now the
government's been thinking for a while
about how exactly to do this and this
replaces an earlier plan that they had
um we think this looks like quite a
reasonable way to tax the women's laws
that these companies are receiving if
you decide you want
um a windfall tax on these profits
foreign
spend much time on there was a common
theme to them
um of real missed opportunities here and
there was a reversal offered cut to
stamp Duty announcing the mini budget I
think it's a bit of a shame of all of
the tax cuts in the mini budget that was
one that I would like to have seen
um perhaps at least the um broad brush
reduction
there was the introduction of being a
collect size Duty for
um electric vehicles now the government
badly needs a strategy a plan for how
it's going to tax our electric vehicles
in the future just putting vehicle
access GMC on them
is not a good plan for how you how you
want to tax them in the long term
and the chancellor slash the allowance
is the amount of dividends and capital
gains that you can receive
um acts free
um
now capital gains tax in particular is
badly in need of Reform you can argue
for or against pressing the allowances
but I think oh well I would say fairly
safely is that it wouldn't have been
near the top of my list of reforms that
we need to help our games tax everything
from
um the release of a business asset
disposal relief to allowing for uh
inflation to the way that it operates um
at death
would be higher priorities
so to sum up
um this was a substantially although not
enormously tax raising Autumn statement
and some of the biggest tax Rises of
course were only temporary and there was
at least one significant tax cut in
amongst the general theme of tax Rises
but overall the chancellor has broadly
opted for a set of well not like
relatively easy Revenue raisers rather
than much needed coherent reform of the
system simply announcing freezes to
thresholds in future years when you've
got very little idea of how big a tax
rise that'll turn out to be is not a
good way to make policy
Nana Harry's like the taxation of
property whether that's business rates
council tax stamp Duty how we should tax
electric vehicles how we should tax
capital gains these are all areas that
need serious thought and well-considered
reform now to be fair the chancellor is
new in person had only a few weeks to
prepare
um a budget in in what has almost
emergency circumstances so I think I
might custom a bit of slack
um on this occasion but I would say I
would hope for some more considered
reform when the chancellor has a bit
longer to think about the issues and
bring forward his plans
at that point I'll stop and hand over to
show away
thanks Joe
okay so I'm going to talk about the
outlook for living standards and
government support for the cost of
living
the outlook for living standards is um
frankly quite dire the obr forecast
um and that real household disposable
incomes will fall by seven percent over
the next two years
now this chart shows the year-on-year
change in real household disposable
incomes over a long period of time we
see that since 2008 we've seen a number
of shops to real incomes many more than
we've seen in previous decades but the
falls in real income were expected to
see in the next two years are far larger
still than the shops in recent history
and indeed they're the largest Falls
we've seen since record began
this comes on top of already more than a
decade of lost growth since the 2008
crisis
um and the obr forecast that we won't
return to pre-pandemic levels of real
household incomes until after the
2027-28 financial year
now the blue line here plus what would
have happened to real householders over
incomes had the pre-2008 trend continued
and I've shown this chart a couple of
times and it gets more ridiculous each
time but according to the obr's
forecasts
um by 27 28 we're going to be nearly a
third poorer than we would have been had
the pre-2008 trend in growth continued
foreign
Outlook in living standards over the
next two years comes despite a large
package of government support for the
cost of living crisis
so the chancellors confirmed that the
energy price guarantee will carry on
into the next fiscal year the typical
household energy bills will be capped at
three thousand pounds a year which will
be which is estimated to cost 38 billion
over the next fiscal year now this
compares to a cost of 55 billion to keep
the cap at the current 2500 pound level
until September 2024 which is what
quasi-quarter intended
the compared to a situation in which the
government did nothing and there was no
energy price guarantee and the median
household would save 270 pounds per year
as a result of the energy price
guarantee
however even with the guarantee most
households will see a large rise in
their energy bills so the median
households will see an increase in their
energy bills of 900 pounds compared to
today when there's a 2500 cap in place
and most households have access to this
400 pound energy rebate
and compared to the last fiscal year
before the energy crisis happened the
median household will see an increase in
bills of the 1800 pounds
now I've said that the median household
will see an increase in 900 pounds in
bills compared to today however this
huge variation in how much energy bills
will increase depending on how much
energy households use so this bar here
plots and the distribution in the
increasing energy build and we see that
one in four households will see an
increase of less than 700 pounds so
that's the 25th percentile whilst more
than one and one in four households will
see an increase of more than a thousand
two hundred pounds
you see this variation in the increase
in energy bills right across the income
distribution
so even for the very poorest households
those in the lowest decile of household
incomes one in four households will face
a rise in energy bills of more than a
thousand a hundred and fifty pounds
compared to today
the Johnsons also announced another
package uh one-off cost of living
grounds totally 11 billion pounds in the
next fiscal year
these grants will be targeted at
specific households
um so there's no Universal component and
the 400 pound Energy discount that
almost all the households got this year
will no longer be in place next year
households on means tested benefits will
receive 900 pounds next year
um with additional support for
pensioners and those on disability
benefits
turning now to ordinary benefits so not
benefits specifically targeted at the
cost of living crisis the chancellor is
committed to operating
um most main working age and disability
benefits with CPI inflation so in April
next year they'll go up by 10.1 percent
now this is a big increase roughly
keeping Pace with inflation
um but it won't make up for the fools in
real benefits last year when the benefit
operating failed to keep up with
inflation and as a result real benefits
won't return to the pre-pandemic levels
until after April 2024. so talk about
this in more detail um in later
um in addition the chancellors announced
a one-off up rating of the benefit cap
with CPI next year
so the benefit cap affects around 100 30
000 households as of May 2022 these are
mostly large households and those with
high housing costs and it's been frozen
in cash terms since April 2016.
um so the the operating of the cap with
inflation is obviously welcome and will
come as a big relief to these households
um however it's disappointing that the
chancellor hasn't committed to operating
um the benefit cap in line with main
working age benefits going forward
um as we recommended in the green budget
and we see clearly that you know
operating the cap by 10 next year is a
positive change but in a context when
prices have increased by 24 and that
still means a big cut in real times
since April 2016.
I should note also that although most
benefits have been operated with
inflation the housing element of
benefits for private renters the local
housing allowance has been frozen in
cash time since April 2020 and since
April 2020 there's been a six percent
increase in average private sector ends
now I've said that
um real benefit levels won't return to
their pre-pandemic levels until April
2024 this is because benefits are only
upgraded once a year with a large
measure of inflation so benefits
operated in April using inflation
measures is in the previous September
and the fact that we've had consecutive
years of rising inflation since the
pandemic means that benefits are lagging
behind the cost of living
and so this chart shows the average
benefit entitlement of out of work
claimants in real terms excluding the
housing element which as I said has been
frozen
um and you see that
um
because of rising inflation the real
value of benefits fell between 2019 and
April 2022
the current operating is just keeping
Pace with inflation so keeping Pace with
this lower level of benefits
and it won't be until April 2024 when
inflation subsides that real benefit
levels actually catch up to their
pre-pandemic levels
so the fact that real benefit levels are
lagging inflation is one of the reasons
that the government's introduced these
one-off cost of living grants another
reason being that lower income
households spend more of their money on
um energy and food which have gone off
steep clean prices
um and we see here that on average
um abstracting from the differences
inflation faced by household so assuming
all households face the same levels of
inflation we see that on average these
costs of living grants um have roughly
kept real benefits at around
pre-pandemic levels
however this is just the picture on
average
and um really flat rate bronze are not a
good substitute for just operating
benefits with um current inflation
that's because there's huge variation in
how much benefits people get so in this
chart I'm plotting the number of
households receiving different levels of
Universal Credit per month and you see
that there's huge variation so 900
pounds a year in the cost of living runs
will be a huge increase for those
receiving very low levels of universal
credits so for example for the 160 000
households receiving less than 100
pounds a month but it won't go very far
at all for those receiving very high
levels of benefits another issue with a
flat rate Grant is that it creates a
cliff Edge to someone at the very end of
the UC taper will be entitled to the
full 900 pounds where someone earning
just above that will receive nothing at
all
so bring together
um the cost of living support the
benefit measures we've seen as well as
the tax measures that talked about here
I'm showing the
um effect of these policies on household
across the income distribution
and we see that before the Autumn
statement yesterday
um there was already a progressive set
of policies planned for the next fiscal
year comparative attacks and benefit
system in November 2021.
so um at the bottom of the distribution
the
um changes to the Universal Credit taper
which make Universal credits more
generous for in-work households as well
as some indirect tax measures what boost
incomes at the bottom of the
distribution whilst freezes to income
tax thresholds
um would reduce incomes for higher
income households
now the measures announced yesterday
reinforce this Progressive pattern with
the cost of living support targeted at
low-income households whilst the rise in
Employments and the lowering of the
additional rate threshold mostly hitting
High income households
the energy price guarantee the savings
and energy price guarantee are broadly
evenly distributed across the
distribution and overall households will
gain in cash terms on average with
low-income households gaining more in
cash terms
um I want to be very clear that I'm just
talking about cash changes as a result
of these policies I'm absolutely not
saying that lower income households are
going to be better off next year given
the rising price levels that they'll see
so looking into the longer term
um to 2027 28 after the temporary
support expires and after the cost of
living crisis subsides
um we see that policies will result in
tax Rises across most of the
distribution
with the Autumn statement reinforcing
previous plans
um so
the bigger thoughts and incomes largely
due to the decision to keep tax
thresholds Frozen up until 2027.
so overall you see that the lowest
income households will see increases in
their income as a result of tax and
benefit changes since November 2021
um and most of the distribution will see
decreases in their income with the
biggest fools coming at the top of the
distribution
so to summarize
um we're heading for another lost decade
of income growth
um with the next two years being the
biggest Falls in real household income
on record
and this is despite another big package
of support
um for households in response to the
rising cost of living crisis
um despite the support the median
household will still face a rise of 900
pounds in energy bills compared to today
and uh a thousand eight hundred pounds
compared to last year
the cost of living support this time
around will be targeted at specific
groups there'll be no Universal element
and as such we can expect some middle
household incomes middle-income
households to really suffer next year
um ordinary benefits so not benefits
related to the cost of living crisis
will be upgraded with inflation next
year however they'll still lag
pre-pandemic values in real terms until
April 2024. now this is part of the
reason for the cost of living grants
that we're seeing but as I said these
fat raised brands are really not a good
substitute for simply operating benefits
with current levels of inflation
foreign
taking the tax and benefit measures as a
whole we see that these are progressive
set of policies
um in the next fiscal year we'll see the
poorest households gaining the most in
cash terms whilst the the richest
households will lose out and in the long
run to 2027 28
um we'll see no tax Rises across most of
the income distribution with the largest
Rising Rises taking place at the top of
the distribution
okay thanks
thank you very much indeed to
um to Carl to Ben to Stuart and to
xiaoway um we've run quite a long uh way
in terms of time with all of that as you
can see there was an awful lot of
analysis there an awful lot to
um see so we will get through what
questions we can there are quite a
number of questions here about growth
and in particular
um anorexic of the Guardian uh
summarizes what quite a number of people
have asked which is could Paul please
spell out what he considers the series
of economic owned goals in recent years
um well I'll offer I'll offer a few my
colleagues might want to come in with
some more but if we go back to 2010 I
think let's start with uh slashing
investment
um spending uh will be will be one um
remember that was something that was
announced under the last Labor
government and continued by George
Osborne reducing uh investment spending
not a good way to get growth cutting
spending education
they're particularly huge cuts to
vocational further and further education
but also to schools over that period and
note while School spending is going up
over the next period uh spending on
further education six or vocational
education didn't get a mention yesterday
that will be number two uh very clearly
brexit was an economic owned goal there
may be other reasons for brexit but
economically speaking uh that has been
uh very bad news indeed and continues to
be bad news particularly the way that
we've done it uh the hard type of brexit
that we've had distancing ourselves uh
from uh from the signal Market
um obviously the um uh the uh mini
budget of a couple of months ago um
didn't help shall we say in fact it was
uh in fact that was another another
large own goal
um Carl Ben particular Stuart do you
want to
um do you have any other big own goals
that you might want to um suggest
if not don't worry
that might be enough own goals
um
doesn't sound like uh doesn't sound like
they've got any other own goals but I'm
sure we could think of a few more if we
had
um if we had the time
um
there's uh there's a series of there's
some sort of more positive questions
about whether the chancellor could have
done more
um to uh improve uh improve the growth
potential I mean as as Stuart said a
little sympathy uh given that he's only
been in post for a couple of weeks
um but clearly there are there are
numerous things that one could do to uh
improve growth again I've already
mentioned the spending on
um uh vocational further education and
so on
um let's hope that we uh do get a return
to looking again at planning at planning
policy
um there's much that could and perhaps
should be done within the tax system uh
Stuart referred to the general lack of
strategy there
um uh there is there remains a lack of
strategy in the corporation tax system
uh Rishi sunak promised a review uh in
the light of the very big increase in
the main rate coming in next year all
we've seen so far in the mini budget is
a is a relatively minor increase in
investment in investment allowances
um again any of my colleagues like to
offer there to penance on what uh you
should actually have done if you really
wanted to get a bit more growth Carl
perhaps you'd like to start
I'm afraid I had to reboot my computer
so I'm only now back I missed the
question ah growth what would you do to
get some growth
um
well clearly what we want is sustainable
growth so this is not about trying to
just put money into the economy in the
short run it has to be about a set of
policies that will increase Trend growth
over the longer term
so you want to look at serious tax
reform uh not just tinkering with some
tax rates you want to look at um
government investment policy you want to
look at education policy you want to
look immigration policy you want to look
at planning law
um whole set of things I think we know
that can be good for growth doing them
isn't easy though there's reasons why
previous governments have shied away
from them and even if you do them and
get them right you've got to be prepared
to understand that the returns from that
will be in the long run so if you get
your education policy right it's going
to be decades before you fully reap all
the rewards from that that's not to say
you shouldn't be doing them
um but there's no quick fixes here
yes I think I think it was Ed Conway who
wrote um slightly only slightly
tongue-in-cheek um in in one of the
newspapers recently that um if you
really want growth you want to concrete
over the countryside and open up the
borders to completely free immigration
uh the point being that there are there
are trade-offs here uh my view is that
on the whole we've been on the wrong end
of that trade-off in other words we've
been we've been in favor of things uh
other than growth
um too much and not being willing to
take some of the costs of growth like
building houses in some people's
backyards building roads close to where
some people live
um are being part of the single market
and accepting some of the constraints of
that and so on
um Ben uh extra cash for the NHS does it
cover cost pressures
before the NHS I've just thought of a
couple of own goals if you want me to
add those oh go on let's have some more
end goals sure so I mean two quick ones
one is just failing to deal with some of
these sort of fiscal problems we've been
able to see a mile off slowly trembling
down the track and it was done nothing
about knowing that we're going to phase
out petrol and diesel cars but doing
nothing about actually implementing any
sort of roadmap towards Road pricing and
dealing with the fact that fuel duty is
going to disappear
not doing things like thinking about the
tax treatment defined benefit pensions
contribution pensions before um
inheritances ahead of time so those
sorts of short-sighted measures and then
on one of the big problems we're facing
as car talked about is this big spike in
debt interest spending part of that is
because as Bank giving as a banking
industry increases its base rate
um that leads to much higher spending on
interest payments on reserves held at
the bank of England that's a falls out
from quantitative easing and uh Paul
Tucker wrote in our recent green budget
about how this was foreseeable ahead of
time and had we taken you know action a
few years ago who could have headed off
that problem and who might not be facing
as big an increase in debt interest
on the NHS uh there's lots of moving
parts and it's hard to reach a sort of
firm conclusion so the NHS had said
originally they reckoned that there were
about seven billion shorts
um because of cost pressures and pay
pressures yesterday they got about 3.3
billion
um the NHS have since said that that 3.3
billion plus about a billion of
efficiency savings means that they're
more or less compensated and it's worth
saying that the extra money comes with
additional demands on the NHS in terms
of what they're expected to deliver
um so I think they look to us like there
may be ever so slightly worse off in
real terms
um but they're now saying they can make
a bigger efficiency savings and maybe it
sort of adds up they're certainly doing
better than other public services that
haven't had any extra cash provided
um and uh I think on there's a
questionnaire about pay and how much
extra pay might eat into that money
available as a sort of rule of film
which isn't precise but actually every
extra percent on the NHS payable costs
maybe 800 million to about maybe to a
billion and so if next year
um rather than giving three percent pay
was they give five percent pay Awards
you might expect about half of that
extra cash to get eaten up but that's
very rule that's back of the envelope
it's not based on any sort of detailed
bottom-up analysis
brilliant thank you
um it's a question from Tom Reese of the
telegraph here
um probably some combination of Carl and
Yahweh I think this is for almost half
the projected increasing wealth was
driven by disability and other benefits
linked to long-term sickness is this
worrying I think the answer to that is
yes
um how does the shrinking Workforce
impact the economy
um there's a question there about
investment as well which seems to be
rather separate but um the the the the
the the increase in welfare driven by
long-term sickness and its impact on the
economy
would you like to have a shot at that
I'm happy to have a go I mean yes it's
clearly clearly of potential concern I
think really we need to work out the
extent to which it's a benefit system
doing a better job of recognizing the
extent to which people have got health
related problems in which case at least
part of the story would be a good news
story but you then still want to tackle
their how do we get people in a better
position how do we help them manage
those health conditions and um you know
have better options in their lives
um and if it's not that then clearly we
want to be thinking about how can we
design the benefit system to make sure
the money's really going to those
um who need it so it's certainly
worrying
um
foreign
the shrinking Workforce with colleagues
have put some work out recently looking
at um people in the Years approaching
state pension age where we've seen a big
drop in uh the proportion who are in
work or looking for work a big increase
in the proportion who are economically
inactive we don't think that the the
increase in the the numbers of people
moving out of work is because of them
being in worse Health we think the
increase in poor health is actually
occurring amongst people who've been out
of the labor market for some time so
there's actually two problems if you
like there's one is why are people
who've been out of labor market for a
while seem to be getting sicker than
they used to and that's something we
certainly need to focus on and as a
second issue which is about why are
increasing numbers of older people post
pandemic choosing to leave the labor
market and is it a choice that they're
happy with that's a good choice for them
in which case maybe it's fine of course
it'll have consequences for the labor
market and for the public finances or is
it potentially something that they will
subsequently regret if for example
they're running down their pen pension
fund and they may find in a few years
time their pension pots aren't as
healthy as they're hoped for so again
certainly something that's worthy of
more study
I think it's worth it sorry sorry go
ahead Joey okay I just wanted to come in
on this point on raising just for these
benefits as well I don't think it is
just a matter of the benefit system
supporting more people because we do
also see a rising share of people
reporting long-time health problems now
as Carl said the extent to which that's
driving the rising in activity we've
seen is unclear does seem like lots of
people are moving into retirement
um although that said
um we we do know that people who report
long-term sickness are less likely to
re-enter the labor market and we have
also seen a decrease in flows out of
inactivity that may be due to Rising
sickness among this already inactive
population so I think that's something
we'd need to dig into a little bit more
um in terms of you know the falling the
falling labor Supply in general of
course that's going to be bad for the
economy that's going to constrain growth
and actually
um relative to the March forecasts
um the uh obr actually downrighted
um growth um due to Rising inactivity
compared to what was expected in March
however that was exactly offset by an
increase in immigration from outside the
EU that they weren't expecting in March
so overall no effect on labor Supply but
um the rising and activity rate are
obviously worrying for growth I think
it's particularly worrying the context
of growth in the 2010s so the obr had a
really interesting chart in the UFO this
year that showed that in the period
between 2010 and 2019
um growth was essentially it was mainly
driven by increasing hours worked
so it's driven by uh increasing the
labor Supply increased hours work of
people you know in work as well as
increased immigration
um with very little growth being driven
by capital investment or productivity
growth if you contrast that with growth
in the period between the late 90s and
before the financial crash a lot of the
growth then was driven by productivity
growth as well as capital investment so
that's a very different picture and now
in the context of you know
at least not Rising immigration
um and potentially falling labor Supply
we're really going to have to look at
how we can get productivity grown again
a really important points there from
xiaoi it's also worth um so it's always
also worth reflecting on the fact that a
lot of people on disability and
incapacity benefits are now relatively
young
um this is uh this is a something which
is particularly affecting uh less
well-educated
um young people particularly lots of
mental health problems uh in that group
big big increases in recent years and
particularly in in spending on personal
Independence uh payment this is
something the government really does
need to uh get to the bottom of and get
a grip on there's a question here um
from Joe Massey to what extent of the
visible tightening due to the mini
budget and brexit he says the obr chair
downplayed
um those
um
it is true that um that guilt rates have
sort of gone back largely following the
mini budget but this um is one of the
other economic owned goals actually
which one of my colleagues has just
emailed me to remind me about which is
that the general economic and political
instability and uncertainty that we've
had over the last several years which
are associated with brexit and also with
that many budget have definitely been a
constraint on growth now three prime
ministers and four chancellors in a few
months and to be reversing policy Here
There and Everywhere
um to be uncertain about your trading
relationship with the rest of you have
cooperation tax going up down and round
and round and round all of that is bad
um for growth and that in some sense you
could say the mini budget was a symptom
of that you could also say it was a
cause of that clearly the economy uh as
the obr itself has said is significantly
smaller as a result of brexit and that
clearly uh makes the um the the fiscal
situation more difficult than it
otherwise would have been
um we've only got a couple of minutes
um
left
um would any of my colleagues like to
pick any particular one of the very many
questions that are still there that
they're really Keen
um to answer I'll give you 10 seconds to
answer that or I will ask one myself
there's a question about schools funding
which is easy to answer that's a good
reason for choosing yeah which is it
going in real terms uh yes sir is yes so
our colleague Luke said yes has shown
that if you just use a GDP deflator for
pupil funding by 2525 it's set to be
above its 2010 level in Real terms in
England if you use Luke's school
specific cost index which allows for
things like better accounts or things
like pay Awards it's still set to be
back at effectively 100 of its 2010
level by 2025 so that's 15 years of lost
schools funding growth if you like but
those cuts uh will be undone and it will
be rising in real terms over the next
few years
quite there's quite a few questions
about the kind of potential coming
spending cuts and how they compare to
the austerity of the 2010s where I think
you know I'm not going to give a
quantitative answer on that essentially
you know did the spending cut through
the 2010s were really very very big they
were much bigger than what's now being
expected over the next few years but I
think it's also a very different context
in 2010 2011 Mr Osborne was trying to do
big spending cuts after a period where
they'd been big spending increases in
lots of areas of government if we try
and do any spending cuts now it will be
coming off the back of several years of
deep spending cuts in lots of areas and
also Public Services which are having to
deal with things like extra
responsibilities because of brexit extra
challenges because of the pandemic so a
much harder era to do a much harder time
to be doing Cuts than it was say in
2011.
right we should stop there thank you so
much everyone I should say members of
the press who have not had their
questions answered or have a further
questions do do feel free to get in
touch
um uh with me or through uh with my
colleagues or through the Press office I
I don't mean this meanly I sincerely
hope that we don't see you again at an
event like this until
after a budget in March I'll be happy if
we have another fiscal event between now
and then uh but for now thank you very
much for coming and watching our
analysis of this event particular thanks
to all of my colleagues who have uh had
very little sleep
um uh over the last 24 hours for another
fantastic Set uh of presentations
everything that you've just seen is on
our website as of now thank you very
much our website as of now thank you
very much